just
and running
yeah
you
here we go just three seconds left
LeBron goes fighting for their playoff
lives
taeju one
differ is going to the lam
that is Madden NFL 17 for PlayStation 4
and Xbox one and as always the game
looks incredible
this year Madden lets you take your team
all the way with the most balanced
gameplay today new ways to play in
franchise mode and an all-new commentary
team it personifies everything we love
about sports passion intensity and of
course competition competition in the
world of gaming is eSports and it's
absolutely electric elite players a
global stage and of course big paydays
from the first Madden challenge 14 years
ago to today's competitive battlefield
scene and of course the FIFA interactive
World Cup EA is no stranger to the power
of elite competition but the spectacle
of eSports barely scratches the surface
of competition it's a select few that
become pro gamers that is why EA is
embracing a new approach to competitive
gaming we want to make stars of all of
our players with new competitive modes
and weekly online contests in our
biggest franchises we're making
competition fun and meaningful for
everyone regardless of their ability as
such I'm excited to announce three
awesome new ways to compete challenge
your events premier events and EA major
events with our challenges series of
events we'll be giving the community an
ability to be more easily hosting and
running their own tournaments next up is
the premier series these are large-scale
live events that will host with partners
from inside and outside of the gaming
world and finally there are EA major
events these are marquee live events run
by EA on a global stage the best players
competing for the biggest prizes and it
all starts this weekend at EA play in
Los Angeles with our first EA major
event the man NFL 16 championship in a
moment we'll welcome ESPN
dan Verret to the stage in LA who will
introduce you to the eight finalists but
first let me two of the fiercest modern
competition out there Eric problem right
and Zack serious mo Lane the greatest of
all time is the guy to beat god just
lose being the best in the world often
inspires all reverence respect when
you're the best in the world at a video
game everyone thinks they can take you
down every day on Twitter or people
coming in saying that they can beat me
usually I just responded and in the
nature of something like you know Floyd
Mayweather doesn't fight you know Joe
Schmo off the street I am the greatest
of all time when it comes to Madden
football I'm here to win and what was in
the way just know another person that's
gonna have to get laid out I'd like to
believe that I'm the best man playing
right give it up for serious no
a lot of people feel it's going to be
serious mom I kind of dedicated my life
to this and I mean when I was 16 I was
like at the top of my class I would like
go to school with like no sleep being up
on that playing that being a full-time
video game player is hard for a lot of
people to understand it is tough it's
tough to do and I'll play as many hours
as I can just to really get ahead of the
competition
both problem and series will have a
claim to the top of the Madden world and
the issue may be settled at the Madden
Championship it's a tournament that
started with a million players and
online qualifiers and ends this week
live in Los Angeles with $50,000 at
stake
these would-be rivals are actually close
friends but don't expect them to take it
easy on each other if they meet with a
title on the line well there's no
question I'm gonna win the Madden
challenge this time around I wish you
the best of luck I gotta beat him
it started with a million players
competing online and now only these
eight remain the best Madden NFL players
in the world all world class competitors
they're at the top of their game but
only one is going to be the winner let's
let's meet one of the guys here who
appears to be a little injured this is
serious mode you saw the piece what
happened I was racing a friend and had
my shoes tied fell down broke my
collarbone didn't have your shoes tied
are they tied now no they're not side
aren't we don't want you to fall off the
stage all right best of luck to you best
of luck to all of you guys now it's
going to be an awesome competition if
you can't be here at EA play to see it
in person you can tune in you can watch
on twitch YouTube or tune in to ESPN 3
to watch all the action live or join us
at ESPN 2 6:00 p.m. Eastern on Tuesday
for the finals now let's send it back to
Peter in London